it's our girl yeah I know and look we we
we do need to get an intro song for this
eventually but we have been a fellas
we've been obsessed if you're new around
these parts and we're on the front page
so there's quite a few new people here
today so by the way before I before I
show you this wonderful stuff here do me
a favor guys hit the like button uh
makes us look cool and uh subscribe
button of course the most important we
want one of them plaques and
make sure that you join our locals you
don't even have to like pay for the
locals but just join it because like
that's that's
seems to have been the easiest way it
seems to be the easiest way to get in
contact with the fans right because like
when you post something on locals it'll
send that an email and go hey you know
blah blah blah notified and it's it's
it's been a lot easier than like you
know I always tell people to check dude
you don't even have to pay I mean we
obviously prefer to do the five bucks
but you just do it for free
because we make announcements and stuff
there and it's a lot easier to get that
stuff out to everyone that's a member
than going like oh check Twitter or
Facebook or Instagram or maybe you
missed the show it's just the easiest
way to keep contact with the show and it
helps us out anyway uh um
Drew Barrymore we have a legend in the
house
drew it to me baby hey he's a legend
because remember that when he he did a
photo shoot for his miscarriage oh that
was [__] remember that unbelievable
that [__]
or Mr egot
for those who don't know an egot is
somebody who wins an Emmy a Grammy an
Oscar and a Tony
um the good news is all those Awards
haven't meant anything for 30 years
[Laughter]
introduce
our question with John Legend
he's a hack yes no I know he's a hack
number one
he is
ah man I got this guy down to a tree
already he self-conscious about his
Heights because those are the shoes that
have an extra have an extra inch tennis
shoes that have an extra inch so sign of
you go the dress shoes some dress shoes
have kind of a lift
um so he's very self-conscious about
that
um he's trying to be like that
soft-spoken safe black guy with his look
like that sweater and and and the tight
pants bro he's a gay guy
I mean it's not a bad way to be
introduced it certainly is not when
you're John Legend
I don't know how you could possibly tell
that this man is gay
Drew Barry well because the sperm
doesn't work uh Drew Barrymore
um
goes to the school of thought that some
women go to school of thought yeah the
school of thought which is lap it loud
means funny
loud means funny
Ricky Lake impression bro yeah this is
basically who Dylan Mulvaney bases his
personality off of yes it is
I heard a story about your table at the
Vanity Fair I heard a story about the
miscarriage photo shoot yeah my producer
you my producer gave you tidbits to
write down on little cards and then they
gave me those cards and it said
something about your table but then she
rolled up those cards and started coke
with them yes that's I love the way they
always do that like I heard this story
about you no no no no no no your
producers went in the green room and
went I know we got to plug the new album
but like what what do you got give us a
cute story or some kind of wacky thing
and then they go back and give it to the
guy that's why Nathan Fielder did
something uh Nathan Fielder had a show
then I recommend it by the way if you
watch it called Nathan for you okay and
and basically what he did was it was it
was a real like one of those reality
shows like kind of like in the vein of
Bar Rescue
except he would go to these real
businesses like real world and they they
come out and said this was real real
world businesses and pitched these crazy
ideas right like one shop we went to a
yogurt shop and he was like look we need
money and so we did so basically he said
we're gonna have a poop flavored yogurt
right and the mentality was like they're
stupid that's so dumb but then the place
did really well because everyone came to
see the poop because they got on the
local news or whatever fine he did one
that was beautiful and he he was on
Nathan Fielder was promoting the new
season of his show and he went on Jimmy
Kimmel so he goes on Jimmy Kimmel and he
tells one of these same stories where
they had to talk to the producer the
whole thing and he's and he goes on
there and the story to surmises very
quick his luggage accidentally got uh
swapped out with somebody else's luggage
at the airport which is a relatable
story happens when he got his luggage it
was a luggage of a fat a fat guy and he
had to go to a wedding well he had to go
to a wedding so the guy goes look just
wear my suit he put the suit and it was
too big for him she took a picture in
the big suit he got pulled over and what
fell out of his pocket was a little
baggie of powder and then the cop when
he goes the cop's like what are you
doing with this bag whatever and then
the guy called the guy that owns the bag
he calls him and he goes hey look
there's a back powder he goes to the cop
the cop goes okay you could be on your
way he goes what was in he goes oh it
was my dad's ashes it was this whole
long story right I do remember and and
if you hear the story that if it's real
that's [__] hilarious right
Jimmy Kimmel says what a great guest
that was so great three months later the
show airs the whole thing was fake he
was like he sat there and he said he
watched footage like this of these
things because he compiled he's autistic
every interview and said okay the best
stories with celebrities are when they
talk about cops or dealing with cops or
getting pulled over that gets the
biggest laugh since Johnny Carson so he
built this old story he goes but you
can't lie and then he showed a clip of
Brian Williams talking about getting
shot by sniper five you lie there's
consequences so he goes so I'm going to
tell the wild story but I have it to be
real so what he went and did was he paid
a guy to go to the airport and get the
same luggage as him
he swapped it out he paid a cop to read
a script and he said what am I going to
do the guy's dad that I use his mother's
is his dad's alive so I can't use the
ashes he had the father clip his nails
and pull some hair out and burn it so
technically it was still his ashes Jimmy
Kimmel had to come out and go I was full
that I cannot believe I fell for it
because and it's true Nathan feel their
show so good because he made the media
look [__] stupid that's really again
oh they're so hungry to get a good story
they're not gonna they don't care they
don't care how stupid it is yep
yes it was the most sought after table
to be at it was a great table why well
oh my God I don't find her that
attractive no to be honest with you well
she's old now
even when she was younger no I was
joking I was talking about Drew
Barrymore because he said I got you uh
you know Chrissy Teigen was never a
thing really to me she's never said that
weird uh the cherubic face it was weird
why does she oh cause that's how she got
it
same joke you get it boys that was
really good that's the same joke you get
it you get it the carting us off of the
field so we can do you know women have
to go through so much to bring life into
the world and breastfeed and all that
and photo shoots
and women have to go through so much
like you know like us you know we have a
nanny raising our kids starts being all
passive aggressive to his wife on TV
it's like oh man all the stuff that
women have to go through to you know
bring a life into this world and you
know and that's for women that you know
get it right
the first time unlike some women but
whatever I'm not gonna get
her feel like [__]
oh well she already had the makeup on
um I want to take the Instagram pictures
see Virgie you could relate to this see
how was your how are your nannies and
chefs are they good with your kids
what
good job
Fergie's like what the [__] are my kids
honestly
bro she's still on drugs right like she
still has to she looks always looks
strung out yeah like she looks like she
wasn't she would die yeah no no I know
but she looks like somebody Drew
Barrymore definitely looks like someone
that is and I know Marshall looks like
that's good at taking drugs
she could exactly she can get through
this whole show she'll read her [__]
lines but also she did a few of them
she might be like 10-15 minutes laying
around there but you know what she's
nice when she comes in Everyone likes
her it's like all right she's cool she's
not me leaving us waiting for [__]
two hours right right she gets here
she's just a hot mess when she gets here
it's whatever we'll deal with it new
Barrymore is that [__] that can still
get quaaludes yes seriously yeah you're
right I figure these are all these are
all leftover staff from shows prior so
it's like leftover or like Ellen I think
Ellen I'm gonna say Ellen and Rosie
and people probably have worked with
Steve Harvey before and these are people
that like well they wouldn't know he's
not allowed to make eye contact that's
what I mean they'll take Drew Barrymore
because she might be a little bit of a
mess but as long as we can keep the
budget of this show down and crank this
crap out and get to the sponsors I'm
sure these people have PTSD from their
former hosts so they're probably like
hey you know what we're never going to
shoot for the [__] stars with the
Drew Barrymore show but you know what I
haven't hated going into work in a long
time and she has the best drugs yeah
she's just all wine drunk all day but
she's nice and she does the air kisses
at everybody and she's all Pleasant I'll
deal with that rather than a [__]
angry lesbian all day goofy boots she
partied at Studio 54 when she was seven
years old yeah she's gonna be [__] up
there's no way not to be [__] she
dated Corey felderman poor [__] girl
man she's been through the ringer so
much and I really mean it on behalf of
all women and moms thank you and it is
you know it is one of those questions
that's normally like reserved also
sometimes for women you know in that way
of like how do you do it all how do you
be a husband a father uh have this
profound career I heard she's going to
do a uh or she's going to do biography
about her life called 50 first date
rapes and it's gonna be no no it's
because they molested her when she was I
got what you meant all right as I was
witty but I didn't need explaining sorry
jeez no because she was repeated that's
not nailed it but anyway is she bad she
married Tom Green remember that she
married Tom oh yeah cause JB said she
dated Tom Green dance not said she
married Tommy that's a good point Tom
green kind of rules I love Tom Green and
dances I wrote and he divorced her he
rules even more now
Tom Green being like look you're a
little too crazy for me saying you're a
little too cluesian you know my bum is
on these divorce papers
excited because you know Tom Green's one
of those guys that probably as soon as
the cameras were off he's like you know
I just like to hang out at home I like
it quiet I like to go to a hockey game
like he's just probably very low-key
dude and she was probably doing coke
nuts and he was probably like I think
she thinks that I'm the on the air Tom
Green all the time and I'm not I'm
actually very nice to my parents when
the cameras aren't rolling
laughs
how do you do it I need to divorce
papers
Clinton I think um you know it's
sometimes it's it's not always easy
sometimes you it must be really because
you know the thing is like it must be
really hard for people like John Legend
we have more money that the generations
of their family could never spend it
must be so hard you literally can hire
somebody to keep an eye on your Nanny
yeah you hear that Virgie stop
complaining just hire a nanny Watcher
stupid
work kind of like has its own momentum
and you're like well I want to
accomplish this and I want to accomplish
that but then you also need to make time
for your family and you're such a floaty
gay guy yes you're such a very gay guy
you're such a floaty like I get it you
know [__] Chrissy Teigen whatever but
you're floating gay guy and the only
reason that she got pregnant is because
dudes suck the [__] out of you and spit
it in her [__] so why don't you [__]
I'm I hate John Legend he's one of those
soapbox [__] guys he's one of those
one of those real BLM like protest Lefty
commie piece of [__] and not even the
BLM stuff because there's some rappers
and [__] that get into the BLM stuff or
whatever but like he's also into the
stuff the stuff that rappers don't get
into except for like the CIA plants like
little nauseations like the gay stuff
into the Tran stuff and that whenever
you see like a famous like say what you
want about like correct me if I'm wrong
and I'm not saying the weekend's not
gonna talk [__] about gay people but the
week ain't gonna go out there and be at
a [__] drag show for kids either you
know what I mean like I don't know man
it's it's you know black people they're
trying to tell you the white man but
let's be we're [__] honest with you
they're trying to turn you all [__]
gay the thing is too is like some of
these people aren't as big of stars as
the weekend the weekend's a [__] Mega
Star right now and they need to protect
him and keep him out of politics that's
part of the reason why that's a good
point like there are certain artists
like John Legend's like Expendable
they've made pretty much most of the
money they're ever going to make off
John Legend there's still some money to
be made but he ain't gonna have another
streak like he had back in the day so
like
you know that this is one of those like
you better come out and you know push
our agenda and we'll let you keep
earning as opposed to like a guy like
the weekend where they probably
specifically tell him stay away from
politics all of it yeah left wing right
wing you're a goddamn Mega star you're
gonna be a [__] household name if you
keep making albums like this just shut
up and make your albums you know so like
I love the weekend that's like he's
probably my favorite artist right now
and they're trying to be like nah man
you need to be the next [__] MJ and
put out albums and make us a lot of
money and then when he starts getting
stale then he'll start being like
protection is good you're like all right
well whatever you know put him out the
pasture basically there were the cushy
retirement plan for them basically yeah